Republicans in Congress refused to fund
a wall so the president announced today
that he plans to send the military to
guard America's border with Mexico the
announcement was sparked by a convoy of
more than a thousand Central Americans
that has been making its way through
Mexico toward this country Mexico's
government claimed on Monday to have
broken up the convoy and deported 400
people in it but people were actually
running that convoy say otherwise one of
them told BuzzFeed quote don't be fooled
the government isn't disbanding it its
conceding its participants right to
apply for asylum without traveling in
the shadows either way we have no reason
to trust the good intentions of the
Mexican government in 2017 the Mexican
Foreign Ministry published a video
encouraging Mexican citizens to break
American immigration law it advised them
not to open their doors to federal
authority it told them to hide the fact
they're there illegally and it was not
the first time the Mexican government
has done this in 2004 the government
printed and distributed more than a
million and a half pamphlets telling
Mexicans how to enter this country
illegally and live here without being
detained it even had tips on what
clothes to wear while crossing a river
presumably the Rio Grande
recently Mexico filed an amicus brief
protesting Texas's anti sanctuary City
bill the Mexican Foreign Minister has
called for illegal aliens in this
country to receive legal status and has
denounced the border wall as quote a
hostile act
hostile Mexico is the hostile power here
just today former Mexican President
Vicente Fox tweeted that Donald Trump is
quote enemy number one of Mexico he then
retweeted someone else who suggested
that if a dispute does happen Trump will
quote probably give back the state of
California the implication of course is
that Mexico really owns California in a
2017 poll 65% of Mexicans said they
viewed the United States unfavorably 42
percent viewed America very unfavorably
none of this should be confusing or a
surprise rather than fix its own
problems which are serious the Mexican
government instead imports them north to
this country it gets angry if we even
hinder that process in any way Mexico is
in fact
using the United States as an outlet for
its ports using our government as its
welfare system Democratic Senator Dianne
Feinstein said that out loud back in
1993 she wouldn't say it today but it's
still true Mexicans in this country sent
home more than 26 billion dollars in the
first 11 months of 2017 the highest
amount ever remittances are one of that
country's biggest sources of foreign
cash bigger even than oil exports and
that's saying a lot the Mexican
government is a corrupt kleptocracy
whose economy is based on oil drugs and
remittances said sent from its
functional northern neighbor that would
be us it's one of the most unequal and
racially biased countries in the world
and yet somehow our mindless
guilt-ridden media say it is racist to
criticize the government of Mexico which
again is a racist government run by the
way by an overwhelmingly white elite
that went to American Ivy League schools
this is insane Mexico isn't sacred it's
a country good and bad but for the
purposes of this conversation it is a
hostile foreign power whose interests
are very different from ours and we
should treat it as such because it is